Hello and welcome to an Apps
Script Crash Course.
I'm Eric Koleda.
And today, we're going to be
talking about Cursor and
Selection within Google Docs and
how to manipulate and read
it via Apps Script.
We recently published a blog
post that goes into the launch
of this feature, as well as some
really good samples that
show how it works.
And today, I'm just going to
give you a little background
into how Cursor and Selection
operates, show you a little
bit of debugging information,
and then also we'll code
together some examples that
use Cursor and Selection.
So before you can really
understand Cursor and
Selection, it's important to
understand the structure of a
Google Doc as it exists
within Apps Script.
Because you will be using that
information a lot when coding
against the Cursor and
Selection APIs.
So a great resource for this is
within our documentation.
We have a page called Extending
Google Docs that
talks about a bunch of different
technology you can
use in Apps Script to extend
a Google Document.
And there's a whole section on
the structure of a document.
And in addition to some
description, we have a nice
tree that basically outlines
what elements can exist within
a Google Doc and what their
hierarchy is like.
So if you've never programmed
against our Document App API
before, do read up a little
bit on this structure.
And then refer to it as you're
coding, as it's very helpful
to kind of understand
how different
elements work together.
Another great tool that I'm
going to show you a little bit
first is called Cursor
Inspector.
So this is a demo that was
linked to in the blog post.
And it allows you to kind of
explore the raw data that
comes back in the Cursor and
Selection APIs without
actually having to do a lot
of coding yourself.
So let's see how this
sample works.
So you can make a copy of this
document from the blog post.
And when you do, you get a
menu that says Inspector.
Click Show Sidebar to bring up
the Cursor Inspector Sidebar.
And now what this does is it's
a page that live loads data
from the Cursor and Selection
and shows you just a raw kind
of dump about what you're
getting back.
So at the very start of
my document is where
my cursor is currently.
And you'll see that my cursor is
within a paragraph element.
And it's at offset 0, and the
surrounding text is the whole
word of that header,
Cursor Inspector.
And [? I'm ?] within
0 within that text.
So let's talk a little bit
about what offsets mean.
When you're in the element
type other than text--
so something like a paragraph,
a table cell, a list item--
those are what we call
container elements.
And they're elements that
themselves are kind of buckets
that hold things.
They can hold text.
They can hold inline images,
drawings, a variety of
different types of content.
So when your cursor is being
reported as within one of
those types, like paragraph
here, the offset means which
element within the bucket is
your cursor in front of.
So right now, my cursor is in
front of the 0-th, or first
element, within the paragraph.
In this case, there's only one
element within the paragraph,
and it's a text.
Now, if I were to move my cursor
one to the right in
between the C and the U, you'll
see that the element
type switches to text.
And the offset is now 1.
So now the meaning
changes slightly.
When you're within a text, the
offset means what character
index within the string
of the text is your
cursor in front of.
So in this case, now it's
in front of the first or
character index 1,
the U, within
the text Cursor Inspector.
And when I get to the end of the
text, you'll see that it
once again switches back
to the paragraph.
And now the offset is 1, meaning
I'm at the end of all
of the things within
my paragraph.
Within the outer paragraph, I
am right before the child at
index 1, which doesn't exist
yet, which means it's very
easy to add a new child
to this paragraph.
So you can use this Cursor
Inspector yourself to play
around and see how Cursor
and Selection change.
And let's see what happens
with Selection now.
So Selection--
I can very simply start by just
selecting some text, like
let's say this U-R-S. You'll
see what I get is
one selected element.
It's a partial selection because
I only have part of
that text element selected.
And then it gives me the indices
within it that have
been selected.
You'll see I have no cursor when
a selection is active.
At any time, you have
either a cursor or a
selection but not both.
Now, if I were to select this
entire paragraph here all the
way from start to end, you'll
see that the element in my
selection changes from a
text to a paragraph.
And it's not partial.
I'm selecting the entire
paragraph.
And the start and end are
negative 1, which indicate no
valid data.
Don't use them.
But the thing about selections,
unlike a cursor,
is that they can contain
many elements at once.
So I can for instance, select
all of these list items.
And you'll see that
they all appear
here within my selection.
And so when you're working with
Selection, be aware that
there could be many things
selected at once.
All right, so now that we
understand the basis of Cursor
and Selection, let's actually
do a little coding.
So I've created a script
attached to this doc.
So I'll go to Tools, Script
Editor and select my script,
Cursor Fun.
Because we're about to
have some cursor fun.
So let's create a new function
that does insertHelloWorld.
This is what we're going to
do first, just kind of
demonstrate how you can use
Cursor API to insert some text
wherever the cursor
is located.
This is useful when you want
to, let's say, import some
information into a document
wherever the
user has their cursor.
So the first thing I need to do
is get ahold of the cursor.
So the cursor is within
the document.
And so we'll use DocumentApp.
We'll get the active document,
which is the one we
currently have open.
And then we'll get the cursor.
Now, like I said, a cursor
may not always exist.
For instance, if there's
a selection, there's
going to be no cursor.
So we do want to test first if
there actually is a cursor
available for us to work with.
And if there is, it's very easy
for us to insert some
text at that cursor
using insertText.
So I'll insert Hello World.
And that's it.
We're done.
So let's position my
cursor somewhere.
Looks like I had an old
Hello World here
from a previous run.
Let's delete that.
So our cursor is right here
in that first paragraph.
And we'll run insertHelloWorld.
Now, I already authorized this
script, but if you haven't,
you might need to
authorize it.
Just a simple clicking
of Accept.
We go back to the document.
And we'll see there's Hello
World inserted in the document
right where the cursor was.
Like I said, now, obviously I
could have just pasted the
word Hello World.
But when you are developing
a script, it could be very
useful to paste all sorts of
automatically generated content.
So that's working with Cursor.
Now let's code up a little
bit of Selection.
So let's say I wanted to take
all the selected text within a
selection and bold it.
Right?
So you can only bold text.
You can't bold images.
So we need to add a little bit
of logic that removes things
that can't be bolded.
And then we also need to add
a little logic that handles
partial selections.
So if I select part of a text
element, I don't want to bold
the entire thing.
I just want to bold the part
that has been selected.
So let's write that function.
So I'll create a new function
here called boldMe.
And much like before, I
need to get ahold of
the selection object.
So in this case, it's still
within the active document.
Typos galore.
And within there is
getSelection.
And once again, we do want to
test to see if there is a
selection, because there
might not always be.
There's a cursor.
And now what we need to do is
pull out a list of all of the
selected elements, so
all of the elements
that have been selected.
Basically, what those rows
in the table were before.
So I'll do var Selected Elements
is selection dot
getSelectedElements.
Now, we want to loop over
these, so we'll do
a simple For loop.
Great.
And now we need to pull out
the element that is within
that selection.
So a selected element
is kind of a
wrapper around an element.
And so you can see a selected
element has the element
itself, whether or not it's been
partially selected, and
then the start and end offset
within that if it
is partially selected.
So I'm going to pull out the
actual element that has been
selected and do a test on it.
So we need to know, can this
element be treated as text?
That means, is it a paragraph,
is a text, is it a list item?
If it can be treated as text,
then we can bold it.
Otherwise, we can't.
So what I can do is do a test
where If the element dot
editAsText.
So it doesn't autocomplete
because it's not in the outer
element class.
But basically, if the element
that we have ahold of right
now has this method available,
then we know we
can treat it as text.
And if this method
isn't available,
then we know we can't.
So now we know it can be
edited as text, we can
actually grab the text.
So I'll do element
dot editAsText.
So there's our text.
Now we're ready to bold this
text, but we need to know, do
we bold the whole thing
or just part of it?
And so for that, we once
again need to do a
test on that isPartial.
So if the selected element is
only partially selected, we'll
do one thing.
Otherwise, we'll do another.
Now, if it's not partially
selected, it's
actually quite easy.
We can just do text
dot setBold.
And we're done.
Now, if it's partially selected,
we have to only bold
some of it.
So what we can do
here is setBold.
And you can refer to the
documentation as to the
parameters.
But the parameters are going to
be the start, the end, and
whether or not to
make it bold.
And actually this takes a True
to make it bold, as well.
So the start is going to
be the getStartOffset.
The end is going to
be getEndOffset.
And then we want to
make it bold.
So we'll put the
word True here.
So just to overview, we grabbed
the selection, we made
sure it was there, we got
all the elements.
For all the elements that can
be treated as text, we got
them as text.
And then if it's partial, we
only bolded part of it.
And if it's not, we bolded
the whole thing.
So let me save my code and
run the boldMe function.
So let me select
some text here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to select all of the
first Kittens, the two pictures
of kittens, as well
as part of the last
word of Kittens.
Now, if we turn back on Cursor
and Selector, you'll see we
have some text, some images,
and some more text.
If we run the boldMe function,
and I go back to my document,
you'll see that the whole first
word Kittens got bolded.
The images were left alone--
they can't be bolded.
And then I only bolded the
second word of Kittens up
until the selection.
So this is a little bit of an
overview about how Cursor and
Selection works.
But there's a lot more
that you can try
out and learn yourself.
Like I mentioned, we did
publish a blog post.
And the URL is going
to be shown below.
Go check it out.
We have some more information
on how to use Cursor and
Selection, some great samples
to try out, and links to our
reference documentation that
give you kind of all the
detail you need to
know about how to
use Cursor and Selection.
Thank you for joining me,
and have a good one.